pouvoir entrer dans un bâtiment qui fait
quatre mille cinq cents mètres carrés
dont 3000 mètres carrés consacrés à la
conservation de ces photos et pourquoi
est ce qu'on a besoin de place c'est
bien parce qu'on est l'un des plus
grands ensembles de conservation de
photos en europe avec 15 millions de
négatifs et on estime à 4 millions le
nombre de nos tirages photographiques
organisés dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine la visite présentait le
cheminement d'une photo à son arrivée
sur le site et le fond très diversifiée
du fort de saint cyr conditionné
documenté restaurée et numérisée pour
être mise en ligne le fond retrace toute
l'histoire de la photographie de 1840 à
on va avoir des fonds qui qui vont du
coup représenter des monuments
historiques et des oeuvres d'art c'est
un plus mais notre coeur de métier mais
aussi de par l'histoire de services
énormément de photographies sur la
première guerre mondiale
et puis des photographies d'auteur donc
des portraits de la photographie dite
plus d'artistique et et la photographie
de cinéma aussi des expéditions
en afrique on a dit
l'océanie plus de 3000 m² héberge ce
fonds composé de différentes donation de
photographe reconnu parmi elles le font
nadara qui en 1950 qui expose un siècle
de photos de la moitié du 19e à la
moitié du 20e siècle
on estime que ça environ 250000 plaques
de verre donc ses négatifs qui vont de
tout petits formats à des flambées est
important et qui représente toutes les
célébrités auquel on peut penser donc on
pense à un peu de lait rahman est à
kourou bert à victor hugo prochaines
acquisitions prévues par le fort de
saint cyr la donation du fonds de willy
ronis